in game two daniel norris comes up from
toledo the practice squad and he'll get
the start for the tigers see if the reds
can cash in as matt davidson stands in
getting the start here in game two from
the belt norris checks suarez the pitch
and davidson breaks his pad as he sends
one of the air and left center that'll
get down for a hit here comes suarez
around third hill scores the throw comes
into second
and it's an rbi single for matt davidson
after a long long at bat against daniel
norris davidson finally wins it and puts
the reds on top one to nothing casalli
was a workhorse behind the plate for the
reds the o2 swinging a ground ball deep
in the hole at short backhanded by
castro turns and flips down to second
almost pulled scope but he got his foot
on the bag for the force at second on
davidson
casiale bounces out the reds take the
early lead and the broken bat fly ball
single off the bat of davidson then
trevor bauer is pitching in game two two
outs and the batter is jonathan scope
the 2-0 to scope
and he's swinging here and he chased a
pitch out of the zone and hits a high
pop-up shallow left out goes farmer
he'll make the play in front of the left
fielder phillip irvin and the inning is
over
no runs a walk and a man left we've
played one
christian cologne 90 feet away with only
one out arcedes aquino starting in game
two as the reds designated hitter and
aquino got one center cut but he lifts
it in the air right center but that will
fall for a hit christian cologne will
score and the reds make it two nothing a
little bloop single into shallow right
the reds have the bases loaded and two
out eugenio suarez at the plate aquino
at third farmer at second castianos at
first
pretty good speed on the base pass
the strike one swinging a high fly ball
left field fairly deep stewart going
back and tracking and he'll make the
catch onto the morning tracking left or
with that wind i was afraid he got it up
i'm with you into the breeze
stewart hauls it in schreiber gets the
out and strands three
grayson grinder will stand in now with
the runner at first and two outs reds
are up two nothing tigers batting in the
second griner swings the first pitch and
hits a bullet speared by suarez at third
he spins to his feet and throws out
mercer at second great play excellent
play i mean that was smashed to his
backhand and suarez makes the play
inning over
and here's christian colon with a chance
to drive home run number three with two
down here in the third the one two
swinging a fly ball left field not deep
stuart ian got a late break now he's
coming in to make the easy grab for the
third hour
jonathan scope steps to the plate back
to the set
and again a breaking ball and it's
popped up to the right side
calling for it is cologne he'll make the
catch two stranded
and through three rents two tigers
nothing runners are first and second
with two outs and a eugenio suarez is at
the plate a ground rule double for
suarez his first time up suarez waiting
the 1-0 he swings and pops it up
right center reyes
demerit it'll be reyes to make the catch
with demerit peeling off and going
behind you
so here's nick senzal senzelle already
with a double in the books
doubled in the third inning fly ball to
center this is deep reyes going back
this is well hit and he will make the
catch tumble to the track hold on on a
deep drive off the bat of senzel
rounding third and holding his casale
that ball was crushed i think the wind
might have fooled reyes a little bit
christian cologne who has doubled and
hit a fly ball to left
the pitch ground ball up the middle on a
big hop to short castro fields an easy
flip over to mercer chest high throw for
out number three
nick castiano's
to right field to merit dives makes the
catch wow
what a grab
great play right there even castillano
salutes that play by travis demerit in
right field travis full superman right
there you want to talk about a hitter
you don't want to fall behind in the
count against a eugenio suarez is that
guy and he is starting to lock in the
2-1
swinging a line drive to left field over
and in christensen
he was battling
davidson has a hit today he's singled
back in the first inning the 2-2
swinging a shot to third knocked down by
lugo he'll reach back pick it up spin
throw and get davidson by his step at
first base second and third only one out
and christian cologne is the do-up
hitter
and a ground ball
into center field to bring in a couple
of runs
christian cologne getting a rare start
and a two-hit game and good for that
young man travis jankowski
at the plate with cologne on it first
3-1 pitch swinging a jam job line drive
caught by scope with a
leap he quickly fired to first what a
job by scope trying to double off
colon colon the veteran got back and it
will be
jammer candelario to hit for travis
demerit bauer
to the plate
curveball pounded into the ground right
side scooped up flipped to first and
that's it a complete game shutout for
trevor bauer
giving the reds
back to back wins for the first time in
2020